Maryna Joyce we've all seen her videos
we've all think we know what happened
she's being forced to make videos
someone who is kidnap her but I'm here
today to tell you I am her kidnapper
I'm the one responsible for marina Joy's
top-quality editing scripted content and
branded advertising it's all been a
social experiment and you've all played
right into my hands don't believe me
I'll show you
everyone knows I am the king of
clickbait and here I taught marina Joyce
how to do it
dyeing my hair pink damn it I thought it
was real
I'm the one that thought marina Joyce
that wig and I taught her all about
clique my hair is not a wig - shut up I
taught her that trick I the one that
needs to be credited that one day I want
to save the animals from positive way I
told her to cry on camera everyone knows
crying on camera equals views to get
your core message across you really got
to hit those points fast marina get it
fast as much information as [ __ ]
impossible go you should watch
conspiracy because it's a very good
thing to watch but it's very gory so I
don't recommend watching it but just on
this wait wait can we repeat that you
should watch cowspiracy because it's a
very good thing to watch but it's very
gory so I don't recommend watching it
damn that's good
here we didn't figure out ten minute
mark yet so we ended the video see the
video ends here at 2:31 and we're like
hey let's make it let's make it three
fifty-eight that's a good number to have
and I wanted to address that because
it's just because I've loaded penis as a
thumbnail and it was not okay
you know my mistake I told her to upload
a penis that's a thumbnail it was a [ __ ]
show here's a picture you can't find it
anymore
I am sorry marina should not take the
blame for it okay and just like this I
really I'm really proud of this video
because we have the background music
which was obviously copyrighted so we
just added another background music
anyway so you get two musics in one hey
guys this video is sponsored by Busey
who is an online fashion retailer
it offers men shame on you be who like
what the [ __ ] you notice she's getting a
[ __ ] ton of you so you're like hey let's
pay let's pay this one because she gets
a lot of views now even though she's
clearly having some kind of mental
breakdown okay which technically I am
making fun of as well but like what the
[ __ ] boohoo come on holy
dance like you're dead inside morena
keep dancing like you're dead inside I'm
a Buddhist
now now we we we told marina to say that
she was a Buddhist but I mean [ __ ]
clearly she's not okay I'm a Buddhist
let's have a look at the but the
Buddhist guidelines to see her okay to
abstain from dancing dancing inspires me
most in life it makes me feel good it
makes me feel incredible I love to dance
and it makes me feel nice so yeah I love
dancing it makes me so happy to da and
use of perfumes ornaments and other
items used to adorn or beautify the
person which is why Marina always of
course has a very no makeup look and to
abstain from using high or luxurious
beds okay we just needed her to be a
Buddhist it's called being part of her
brand okay sorry
it doesn't match perfectly I started
this because I needed use now Marina
Joyce doesn't want to work with me
anymore and I'm exposing her okay
zoom in on the teddy bears I assume you
know that reflection that's me that's me
right there and you open your eyes yeah
do you see the cat that's not a real cat
that's a robot that's a robot cat that I
used to spy on her
Maryna this is for you stop stop this
nonsense that you're doing okay I don't
appreciate it we used to be a team don't
you care about friendship I thought you
were a Buddhist come back to me marina
and we will roll the galaxy alright so
everyone went crazy with marina joys and
like everyone thought she was in trouble
something bad happened to her she
obviously said she was fine everyone
just needs to [ __ ] off and not be an
armchair psychologist don't send marina
Joyce any hate after making this video I
am all about the hate and the Buddhism
love thank you guys so much I love you
guys so much
leave it like if you enjoyed this video
and I'll see you bros in the next video
brofist what is she looking at when she
says that
cameras right here got it what do you
look at don't this is a video she oh my
god